yesterday my two-year-old was playing
with a book that has you connect a color
to a fruit and I realize that would be
the perfect feature to demonstrate drag
and drop and flutter in today's video
we'll build a simple kids game that
allows you to drag a fruit over to a
square with the corresponding color if
you drop it on the correct square it
will update the score and also give you
some audio feedback if you're new here
like and subscribe and you can find the
full source code on fire ship bio now
before we get started a lot of people
have asked me when I'm going to release
a full flutter course the answer is very
soon it'll be released before Google i/o
which is now only six days away so
expect more details on that in the next
few days now let's go ahead and take a
closer look at the app we're building
today you'll see two columns here and
you can grab an item from the column on
the left and then drag it to a target on
the right if it's the correct color it
will mark it as correct and then update
the score but if it's dropped on the
incorrect target then it will just go
back to its original position and then
we'll also randomize the ordering of the
targets for each round just so there's a
little bit of replay value and as an
added touch we'll play a little sound
effect every time the user makes a
successful drop if we jump into the code
the first thing we'll look at is the pub
spec amyl file the only dependency
outside of flutter is this audio players
plugin I really like this plug-in
because it works on both iOS and Android
and also allows you to play multiple
audio files simultaneously and that
tends to be pretty important if you're
building a game and you'll also notice
that we have an mp3 file here registered
in the assets directory and I've also
registered a custom font called press
Start which you can download from Google
Fonts that'll give you that kind of
pixelated retro look now moving on to
the source code I'm importing dart math
as well as the audio players plug-in
then we'll update the font family in our
theme data and then we'll set the home
page as this color game screen that
we're about to define now the screen
itself is a stateful widget and the
first property we'll define is the score
which just starts out as an empty map
eventually we'll update the keys on this
map when the user drags a draggable
widget on to the correct drag target the
next thing we'll define is a map of
choices and so each emoji which is a
string will map to a material color
emojis are really handy because they not
only provide a graphic that we can use
for the UI but we can also use them to
organize the game logic itself for
example if the user correctly drags to
the Green Square then we can update the
score with the corresponding emoji key
will also define an integer here
seed which will be used as a random seed
to shuffle the order of the items as we
loop over them and then we'll use the
audio cache class to play a local mp3
file and we'll call that our audio
controller from there we'll set up a
scaffold and in the app bar for that
scaffold will display the score and then
we'll have a floating action button that
allows the user to reset the game we can
display the score by setting up a text
widget and then to calculate the score
all we have to do is look at the length
of that score map and you can use the
dollar sign brackets to interpolate an
expression directly inside of a string
and dark now the purpose of the floating
action button is to reset the game so in
order to do that we'll call set state
and then we'll clear out all of the key
value pairs inside of that score map and
we also want to add some randomness
after each game so we'll increment our
random seed by one that takes care of
the outer UI now we'll set up a row that
has two columns laid out side by side
the draggable stuff on the left with the
drop targets on the right so the first
column in the row will take care of the
draggable widgets and we'll want each of
our six choices to be a draggable widget
so we'll go ahead and loop over the keys
in the map and if you remember from
earlier each key in that map is just an
emoji string now we're ready to start
using flutters draggable widget which
allows the user to drag a child widget
around the screen now there are three
different things you might want to
display with a draggable widget the
first one is just the default child
which is what will be displayed when the
user is not interacting with it when the
user starts to drag that will open the
door to two additional UI elements the
initial child disappears and then we
have this feedback widget which is what
is actually being dragged around the
screen and then we also have the option
to define a child when dragging widget
which will be displayed to replace the
original child when it's being dragged
now getting back to our code there's one
important thing I want to point out here
and that's that if you're passing data
from a draggable widget to a drop target
you should provide it with a generic
type that represents the data that
you're passing to the drop target which
in our case is just a string then to
actually pass the data we'll go ahead
and define the data property as our
emoji now at this point we're ready to
define the three different widgets which
include again the child the feedback and
the child when dragging now depending on
your UI this may be a good opportunity
to refactor your code into a different
widget in our case here all three of
these widgets are very similar so we'll
go ahead and define a new stateless
widget called emoji that takes a string
emoji as an input then down here in the
build
method I'll start by defining a material
widget and the reason I'm starting with
this material widget is because for
whatever reason the draggable feedback
doesn't seem to want to inherit the
textiles from the main app and then the
rest of it is just very basic flutter
stuff like a container that's aligned to
the center that has a specific height
and width but because we extracted this
logic into its own stateless widget we
can now reuse it three times up in the
draggable widget in a very dry and
maintainable way so we can use our emoji
widget up here as the child and when
passing in the actual emoji argument
we'll go ahead and check to see if that
one's already been answered correctly if
it's been answered correctly we'll just
display a check mark otherwise we'll
display the emoji itself for the
feedback widget we'll always just want
to display the emoji but you might want
to add some box shadow or maybe make it
larger here to give it the effect of
being grabbed and lastly we can use the
emoji widget as the child when dragging
property as well
and that's all it takes to build a
draggable widget and there's also a
number of different callbacks that you
can listen to on draggable to handle
different UI interactions based on the
state of what's being dragged but in
many cases you want to drag something to
a specific location and have it interact
with a different widget which we can do
with a drop target in our case we're
going to build multiple drop targets and
each one of those targets corresponds to
a specific emoji that is allowed to be
dropped on top of it we'll go ahead and
loop over the keys in the choices map
again but this time I'm going to define
a function called build drag target that
will build the widgets for each
individual drop zone then I'm going to
call dot dot shuffle with our random
seed and that will randomize the order
of the items in this list the two dots
here are called cascade notation and
dart and they allow you to make a
sequence of operations on the same
object in this case shuffle doesn't
actually return the array it just
mutates the original so without the
Cascade notation we'd have to create a
temporary variable just to shuffle the
array which would take a few more lines
of code that's just one of the many ways
that dart makes life a little bit easier
for you now we're ready to define the
actual drag target and we'll want to
make sure to pass in the generic string
type here for the data type that we're
dropping on top of this target the next
thing we'll do is define its builder
function which gives us access to the
built context a list of accepted data
and a list of rejected data we can use
that data to determine how the UI should
look for the dragged target now in our
case we're keeping track of the score on
the parent stateful widget
which means we can just look at the
score map for this particular emoji to
determine which UI elements to show if
the users already answered this one
correctly then we'll just display a
white container that has the text of
correct but if the user has not answered
this one correctly then we'll go ahead
and display a container that has the
corresponding color to that emoji and
again that data is contained in the
choices map which we define at the
beginning of the video but how do we
know whether or not a user has actually
dropped something on the dragged target
and whether or not that's valid data to
be dropped there in the first place we
can decide if the data is valid or not
by defining this on will accept function
this will fire when the user drags
something on top of the target so in our
case we can look at the data or the
emoji string and make sure that it
matches the emoji of this particular
widget in other words you should only be
able to drop the tomato on the red drop
zone that'll fire when the user first
hovers over the dragged target but when
they actually drop the item and it's
accepted it will fire this unaccept
function and we also have on leave if
it's drop and it's not accepted or if
they just leave the drop zone altogether
when the user makes a successful drop
we'll go ahead and call set state and
update the score on the stateful widget
in addition we can also play a sound
here which we can easily do with our
audio controller by calling play and
then passing it the name of our mp3 file
and that's all there is to it we now
have a fully functional drag-and-drop UI
and I think the only possible way to
make it better would be to add in some
annoying mobile ads but we'll save that
for another episode I'm gonna go ahead
and wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
consider becoming a pro member at fire
ship IO to get access to the upcoming
flutter course thanks for watching and I
will talk to you soon I choose chunky
style dope
wholesome chunks ruin kids need
[Music]